walking up to this video playing the
Blitz kicker let's kick off from in the
Netherlands no name right no yeah the
Netherlands they have many many good
good players many good blitz players and
tear up the players let's see the semi
tirage this is an opening that is really
making a comeback recent recent times
young not sure I can came lo que bonito
I need to play play actively in the
center of course maybe I can now take on
d5 to set up this typical ram structure
it's really caught the rim hmm maybe
195 it's also not not looking like a bad
move okay isolated Queen porn I'm ideas
Queen def three but he might have my
deffff I of this this could be a good no
no night at 5i can take
hmm I forgot about it I thought this is
not possible but of course it is okay I
need to simplify things then what now 96
let's not take to grind this looks a bit
tactically vulnerable this position but
let's not seem to be the case check the
beat eggs so I have this nice fish at
one age 60 s got some problem with the
back rank but he's attacking deform
hmm i don't really see a way forward at
some it's certainly not a bad position
for white but how do I actually play
Jim strange really yeah but before it
was a weakness what can you do still
he's got this back rank issues I came
take here and be five yeah it should be
it should be enough really to to be okay
with the King position I don't think he
can play for win him take and play but
him he can he has problems to achieve it
i I assume my next move was look on the
seventh yeah should be enough to draw of
course that's not a particularly great
result but but probably nothing better
was possible see going forward d eight
maybe yeah but it's not also not helping
really check
check yeah check i have no way to play
for when you love Allah no way I'm a
pawn down and I don't see how I could
could do anything here I need to I need
to play those repetition moves Kim jack
maybe this one yeah but does not really
does not really do anything I can I win
the porn but this also means that let's
say he does nothing yeah something like
something like that my rook I mean it
needs to move at some point on the
sixth-ranked and then as king as
escaping it's um it was just enough to
draw yeah yeah probably around T I need
to improve after that I ever you know
don't know how to how to improve here
anymore this hangs on the same side but
I need to clarify the situation now and
there are various ways to do that maybe
I have some other move order but check
yeah this is entirely entirely forced
yeah this is this is really fast
absolutely nothing nothing possible him
I what black can try which I what I
overlooked he can do that and you to
play the rook endgame but yeah he won't
get anything better than then this
probably and this is really just the raw
for against 3 g.r probably relatively
correct draw what can you do thanks for
watching